herzlich willkommen zum heutigen video
leute ich sitz hier zusammen mit luca
zwischen uns befindet sich eine pipe
band und vielleicht erinnert ihr euch an
dass videos heißt und so machte
ja wieso war zwischen uns weil wir
probieren dem anderen einen gegenstand
zu beschreiben und er muss überlegen ob
das beschriebene wirklich so ist oder ob
man das erfunden und ich sage jetzt zum
beispiel luca ich habe in meiner hand
den schlüssel zu einem wohn und bald ist
dadurch aber jetzt steht das prinzip ist
lustigerweise auch das meist geklickte
videokanal zu müssen und ich würde sagen
schere stein papier wer anfängt wenige
hersteller für ohne zu gucken dann hatte
ich war gut sie ist die erste sache
kantersieg quantya leute wege zeichnen
diesen nischen also max ich habe hier
einen kopf ein menschenkopf einen ja ich
würde sagen menschenkopf okay es im kopf
das steht auf der seite von dem kopf da
sind nur bis zum kopf haben ist die
frage ich glaube ich sage dass du dafür
ist kommt zum anfang an ich einfach mal
locker liegen weiter glaubt er man fall
gelöst
hallo herr wir sind rein bekommt den
kopf
natürlich haben nichts gehört davon gar
nichts wenn ja ich habe er von wasser
genommen einmal so ding gemacht damit du
denkst ja vielleicht eine wasserflasche
ich habe das war schon viel zu aufwändig
eigentlich ich habe daran ein
unbeschriebenes blatt papier eine
unbeschriebenes blatt papier was ist
wenn die leicht ein loch in der mitte
nein das du hast was anderes garrigues
hört man ja das ist ein weißes blatt wir
das hilft nicht weiter
dabei soll ist in blaues bleibt ihnen
keine ahnung ich dachte hier sind du
kannst
ich habe hier mein ohrenstöpsel vier
stücke okay die haben es garantiert und
gesehen ist nur die frage ob du weißt
dass ich sie gesehen habe oder ob du
denkst ich hätte sie nicht gesehen und
denkst du auch voll komisch was denkst
du ich glaube ich hab keine du hast oder
meerrettich hat jude lacht ja ich finde
richtig nutzen wird
das geschäft ist hausmann gibt geschenke
zurück das geschenk ja ich halte in
meiner hand ein buch und zwar einen
sexratgeber die werte des jana lacht ja
hast du das
ich hoffe nicht werden da ist es besser
auf das gute buch aber es war besser
danach bleiben zu können sollten öfter
völlig leer hat monatelang auch der
einzelne muss ja nicht zu schnell
es steht 1 zu 1 nächste sache klopapier
nein ich halte in meiner hand wie
verantwortung eine parfüm probe
[Musik]
ja natürlich rücken zeigen ich kann
nicht so hoch kommt ja gar nicht gehabt
ich halte nein in meiner hand eine
findet nemo box eine boss eine findet
nemo so eine sammelbox von bvj box also
im prinzip ist dieses spiel einfach nur
raten variante von einer gewissen form
schon wie man das vorbereitet wie man
ich sage einfach ja
[Musik]
hey ich hatte in meiner hand ein parfüm
tester nein ich halte nur zweimal
ich habe in der hand eine ich hab's doch
dafür mit tory ich habe nein gesagt ich
habe aber gar nicht gesagt wie steht
eigentlich viel zu 340 k manchmal
müssten stehe die sache vielleicht haben
nicht begriffen
ich habe meine hand so ein kreis geformt
dass geformt da verliebt ich halte meine
hand ein messer als er das ist jetzt nur
raten war dass der garten besser ja wie
stehe ich würde du führst und zwar mit
das war jetzt ein zweiter punkt
vorsprung auf 523 führst du das ist ja
meine letzte chance noch mal auf einen
punkt an luca ranzukommen wenn er das
jetzt schafft mich damals so verarschen
geht die heutige partie besser üben an
luca und wenn ihr jetzt fünf leichter
davon machen wir es vielleicht anders
mit jana und jude also zusammen immer
okay jetzt lassen sie schon aufgeholt ja
ich halte in der hand einen nasen in
algier stift mit einer kette wo ich
wissen was das ist der hat sich extra
schick gemacht
denn der muschel kette um nasen
inhaliert stift mit einer kette das
innerliche den stettiner haff in all
ihren film ich sage ja komm letzte
chance ihre schätze wir wirklich ticken
okay leute letzte chance jetzt überlegen
ob wir nach vorne
ich halte in meiner hand eine schrauben
muttern
warum nicht ein vater als sex ist denn
von mach mal bereut
ja das gehört interesse ist eine
schraube keine mutter ist ein
ich habe hier noch die sonne mond sterne
fanden marken buchstaben m und mikro ja
drei punkten
ich würde sagen das video habe ich nicht
gewonnen ich habe gewonnen
hallo kann sich beim nächsten video
wieder das heißt ein bisschen komisch
endlich wieder richtiges ende weiter
erst mal keiner bank fern hieß es